a machine that makes other machines is
what elon must call the greatest
production plan of current times the
gigafactories what are these monstrous
industries and why are they so important
not just to tesla but for the tech
industry as a whole why are they the
future and what more promises does elon
have in store for us stay tuned to find
out now first up what does the word
gigafactory actually mean as we know
giga is a unit of measurement meaning
billions the owner of tesla elon musk
coined this term as he laid the
foundation for the first of his
production unit but now this description
is used to cover massive scale
production units that are built in
stages and promise efficient low-cost
electric batteries in a very short time
elon can call dibs on the name however
as almost everyone in the technology and
automation industry refers to his
production units as the gigafactories up
next how many gigafactories are there
and where let's take a look though tesla
has production units all over the place
a few of its completely autonomous units
are referred to as gigafactories how
about we start on them chronologically
gigafactory one giga nevada 2.4 billion
dollars tesla broke ground on this
project in june 2014 outside sparks
nevada the factory is a formidable
structure located east of reno in nevada
usa it spans over a massive area of 1.9
million square feet has an operational
area of 5.3 million square feet and has
a height of 71 feet but it isn't even 30
percent complete yet if it reaches its
full potential this monstrous industry
will have the largest footprint in the
entire world and will be the only
self-sustaining energy plant but what
does this factory produce well the
facility created in partnership with
panasonic with several of its machinery
and products also purely owned by
panasonic produces battery packs for all
tesla vehicles except for the ones
produced in gigashanghai not only that
but it is also the electric vehicle
component and assembly unit for tesla
electric mobiles this place employs more
than 10 000 people giga nevada is also
aligned untrue north so that its
equipment can be tracked by gps and the
solar panels on the roof can be
accurately aligned now tesla has a basic
goal production is more important than
products this means it employs more
engineers to create production machines
rather than focus on the product but do
you know what the drawback to this aim
is it means more wastage a report from
2019 quotes how half a million battery
cells per day were scrapped because of
production defects related to
carelessness or the overall pressure to
increase production the main product
lithium ion cells also called 2170 cells
are assembled and packed by humans and
robots while drive units for tesla cars
including motors and gearboxes are made
with 90 of automation the minimal
involvement of humans shows one thing
that tesla uses human resources mainly
for innovation and saves massively on
resources by automated production robots
not only that but this gigafactory aims
to shift entirely on solar panels as its
energy source making it self-sustainable
now the big question what's the cost of
tesla's first and largest plant though
this is a very rough estimate the
economic impact of such a factory comes
to a massive five billion dollars a year
this is besides the original
construction costs which were around 2.4
billion dollars this unit set the
blueprint for the construction of its
peers gigafactory 2 giga new york 1
billion
tesla and elon musk have said this quite
a lot of times green energy is the
future tesla wants to shift away from
using depleted sources like water coal
and petroleum for energy to using
nature's biggest energy source the sun
with his company that goes by the name
of solar city elon musk has
revolutionized the solar panel industry
by making cheap cost-effective and
commercially practical photovoltaic
cells he wanted them to be introduced
into the domestic circuit as well and
has so far been very successful in his
ventures giga new york is located in
riverbend buffalo new york is owned by
the state of new york and has been
leased to solar city the groundbreaking
ceremony for the 1.2 million square foot
factory was done in september 2014.
production soon began first in
partnership with panasonic and then
independently by solarcity for
photovoltaic cells and commercial solar
panels the factory employs over 1500
people and aim to increase except that
the pandemic hit employment rates a lot
however production is back on track
after the ease of restrictions the solar
cell production unit is still taking
baby steps but is worth a stupendous 750
million dollars it hopes to increase
production and the rate of employment
soon an audit published in 2018 put the
total cost of buffalo gigafactory at
just shy of one billion dollars to build
gigafactory 3 giga shanghai 2 billion
the united states isn't the only place
that can boast of tesla production units
china is no one to stay behind in the
race of sustainable transport and so it
currently hosts the final assembly unit
for the tesla model 3 and tesla model y
of the tesla automobiles produced in
what is known as giga shanghai the
factory is currently one of the largest
production units that tesla can boast of
with a massive area of 9.3 million
square feet it is located in the city of
shanghai china secured within the pudung
district the sheer size of this factory
is intimidating because it has a maximum
capacity of 18 million square feet and a
height of 100 feet but that was just the
size what does this unit actually
manufacture the factory currently does
the final assembly and production of two
of tesla's vehicles the model 3 vehicles
and the model y vehicles though their
component parts are shipped in from the
usa this factory has a name in mind and
that is made in china yes that's right
they want this unit to be completely
autonomous for the production of
electric cost-efficient and smart
vehicles targeted directly at chinese
consumers it currently employs around 2
000 people and produces a massive number
of seven hundred thousand cars per year
some of those are also exported to asia
and australia now we know what you're
thinking that a unit as large as this
must cost a huge amount of investment
you're right on track because giga
shanghai whose construction started in
january 2019 has so far cost around
10.85 million yuan per 7200 square feet
do the math and it comes to at least a
two billion dollar investment and that's
just the beginning because as we told
you earlier gigafactories are built in
phases with each phase fueling the cost
for the construction of another one
until the unit becomes completely
independent news has it that
construction phase three of giga
shanghai has begun
gigafactory 4 giga berlin 7 billion
europe has been thrown into a frenzy
because of the current revolution in
energy consumption the world is
demanding electric cars as an
alternative to fuel consuming cars and
that has put asia at the forefront
because it supplies electric batteries
so it doesn't come as a surprise that
there was quite a scramble among the
european union countries when tesla
announced the plans of opening another
gigafactory everyone knows the economic
spurt associated with the gigafactory
germany won the competition however and
giga berlin came into existence in late
2021 its construction had begun as early
as 2020 after a deal with germany was
signed the factory spans over three
square kilometers with additional areas
for offices and logistics the factory
has so far cost a whopping 7 billion
dollars employs over 8 000 people and
aims to manufacture batteries battery
packs and powertrains not only that but
it's aiming to be the assembly unit for
model y tesla vehicles and other
electric cars in the future tesla held a
huge fare after the construction was
completed to invite tourists to come and
look over the factory where it also
announced that the plant will be
efficient enough to produce one car
every 45 seconds will tesla be able to
manufacture up to its claims or will
asia still take the lead when it comes
to green energy production let's wait
and see
gigafactory 5 gigatexas
1.06 billion
though not exactly a gigafactory yet in
terms of production we have included
this last unit in our list as well
because tesla has planned to expand the
factory into an automobile and cell
manufacturing unit as well the giga
texas is located in austin texas and
also serves as the corporate
headquarters for tesla its construction
began in 2020 and the first tesla model
y rolled off the factory in late august
2021 under the trial process the factory
and training center which employs
several thousand people covers an area
of around 10 million square meters the
factory is planned to be the main
production unit for the tesla cyber
truck and the tesla semi it will also
produce model 3 and model y cars for the
eastern united states the facility which
is currently in its early stages has an
estimated combined cost of 1.06 billion
dollars it seems like elon musk really
likes playing with big numbers when it
comes to his money huh but is that all
definitely not an honorable mention in
this list would be the fremont factory
located near san francisco it is said to
be the mother of all of tesla's
production and the place where its
initial projects began the factory
offers 5.3 million square feet of area
and houses over 10 000 of its employees
apparently the usa and europe aren't the
only options on tesla's plate rumors
have it that tesla is planning another
gigafactory in asia but not in china
where could the possible location be we
think it will probably be in japan or
south korea though these are just rumors
it would be kind of practical to make it
in japan with panasonic so close however
nothing is confirmed as of yet a lot of
people speculate that after brexit the
gigafactory uk is in the cards for the
billionaire elon musk it's kind of
doubtful though with giga berlin so
close at hand and the uk not making
investment offers to elon musk do the
british really want to stay on top of
the sustainable energy revolution wave
let's see and while tesla has always
flirted with the idea of a new
manufacturing unit in india it seems
like this may be a reality after tesla
incorporated an indian business unit
into its company the company wants to
dive into the south asian market and
would have done so earlier if it weren't
for the high import cost associated with
establishing an indian gigafactory but
the indian government is offering
tempting investments and several sites
and we think it's only a matter of a few
years before tesla takes up the offer
at this point we think it's pretty safe
to assume that give or take a few years
tesla will be in the lead when it comes
to the production of gigafactories while
the world progresses towards sustainable
energy because of depleting resources
gigafactories will become the norm with
automation rapidly replacing human labor
and reducing costs drastically well what
did you think about this video let us
know in the comment box below and before
you leave don't forget to subscribe to
the channel and leave a thumbs up do you
want to know which company is secretly
beating tesla and why well click the
video on the screen to find out